eu sou linda mais um vídeo e hoje vou
ensinar como fazer uma arma que dispara
elásticos utilizando dois caminhos de
maneira que toda a gente em casa como
este aqui é isso que está a arma em uma
casa da hera que para só o elástico o
setor não fazer o último deles
utilizando bebidas que param mais para
fazer alguns disparos conta que os copos
letras fez aqui uma coisa pra fora
elásticos que a fita e outra aqui que a
ajuda seja torna o processo quer ganhar
mais rápido do que os no bolso
eis agora vou ensinar como fazer esta
arma passa passa então bora por começar
tem de montar dois kits de madeira mas
façam isso com cuidado porque quero
parar no quintal pode saltar contra
vossa cara ou seja tem que usar proteção
logo desde o início
depois tem que ter esta parte das
conexões que fica assim mãe perfeitas e
para isso usa uma serra frontal mas
vocês podem usar outra coisa a não ser
mandar muito bem conta do trabalho
embora tenha esta partida assim maio
retangular e também terá uma das
extremidades e depois desgostar usando
aqui no lixo ou então podem fazer cortes
em com faca do green mas tem que usar
luvas para isso aí eu vou encaixar uma
parte da mola e vai servir o pedido já
que o punho o arame no suco e depois vou
fazer com um furo na parte da frente da
bola que passa pela mola e por um
pretinho daquela parte de madeira de
baixo
encaixei lá um pedacinho de mais ou
menos 3 centímetros um pontinho deputada
e prende com super cola que já foi
bastante simples mas funcional
agora para o corpo vocês têm que juntar
uma parte do que habita a outra e depois
tem por cola só numa das partes do que a
bíblia encaixem o carro para fazer e
crone encaixe um pedaço por baixo e vão
ajustando ano até que vocês deixarem que
está bom quando estiver faça uma linha e
corta
e para finalizar claro tem que usar esta
parte o registro da arma
agora a krones ficar assim vai ficar
muito fraca então convém vocês forem
dadas nesta parte final também e arma já
está feita a partir de que errou por
assim umas coisas da estréia que não são
necessárias para ela funcionaria se
vocês pararem que forem usar tudo bem
jataí o corpo da arma feita e o sistema
do tipo funcional
aí vou colocar um sítio na praia vou
colocar dois lugares
vocês podem por elásticos aí uma fita
que permite que vocês ponham as costas
aí eu vou aproveitar agora este momento
para dizer que hoje vai ter lá no canal
é a primeira life que vou fazer neste
canal e não sair como é que vai ser eu
já fiz uma fisionomia no canal do mastro
invenções e foi super bacana então seria
fazer uma também aqui no meu canal e ver
como é que isso funciona tem que ir
agora vê tutoriais de como fazer uma
live por que participar é diferente de
fazer a live e agora vou encaixar os
elásticos como vocês não podem mais de
três em cada suporte porque depois
quando forem tirar vão tirar mais do que
um ao mesmo tempo que é isso é isso aí
pessoal chegamos ao fim e também atriz
tido vocês gostaram iremos acompanhar
para ver outras criações minha é alguma
sugestão é se deixar os comentários que
depois de varejo e tem que fazer é isto
que vai ser o próximo projeto é deus é a
próxima a ser palco de proteção